piller
à Ajay
Est arrivé
qu'un
Nous pouvons le nettoyer complètement en une heure ou deux.
Vous aviez quitté vos terres et vos maisons.
Mais peu importe, les Blancs aiment ça
Ce n'est pas visible, c'est du tissu intérieur, c'est à l'extérieur.
elle ne vient pas
[musique]
à Ajay
fais-le
Les gens vont chez nous et s’y assoient aussi.
Il n'y a pas de peur du changement climatique, poulet
Ils pensent qu'il est naturel que quelqu'un vienne
Nous comprenons qu'il s'agit d'un désastre provoqué par l'homme.
La façon dont nous avons ruiné le voleur maintenant
L'un de nos téléspectateurs, Ustad Mataram, a déclaré que
Ce domaine qui est le domaine des colliers, on vient ici.
fait une fête
qu'un
fais-le
Si une disposition est prise, alors dans le passé
Il y a eu beaucoup de chutes de neige et cette chute de neige
Ce qui se produisait en décembre-janvier à cette époque
Non
Il y a de la chaleur en décembre-janvier que l'on voit
sont en train d'être